changed the course of 20th century
history his legacy though is valued more
by some than by others
in the west he's revered as a great
statesman a nobel peace prize winner who
played a decisive role in ending the
cold war
to many russians he's the man who
allowed the soviet empire to collapse
exposing millions to hardship and
humiliation his legacy is that he
allowed for the peaceful collapse
of the soviet union he did not use
massive force to keep eastern europe uh
in the empire
and for that he deserves credit
but it is not that this was someone who
came in trying to undermine the system
he tried to reform it as a young man
gorbachev studied law at moscow state
university he went on to forge a career
in the communist party eventually
becoming its general secretary and
leader of the soviet union but the
command economy gorbachev inherited was
failing and there were shortages of food
and consumer goods
gorbachev tried to fix things with
glasnost and perestroika reforms that
were to revolutionize the soviet system
we need more enterprise more democracy
more organization and more discipline
then we will be able to bring
perestroika up to full speed and give
new impetus to developing socialism
his leadership also led to a revolution
in relations with the west face to face
with u.s president ronald reagan
gorbachev signed a treaty eliminating an
entire class of nuclear weapons curbing
the nuclear arms race
it was the beginning of the end of the
cold war soon the berlin wall fell
and after a failed coup by hardliners in
moscow the soviet union itself was
dissolved and gorbachev resigned
in this situation which follows the
establishment of the commonwealth of
independent states i hereby cease to act
as the president of the soviet union
awarded the nobel peace prize in 1990
gorbachev remained in the public eye
watching democratic progress erode and
relations with the west deteriorate well
right now the present russian czar
vladimir putin is trying with military
force to rebuild the soviet union to
reintegrate it through forceful means
kind of undue
the gorbachev legacy
the united nations secretary general
antonio guterres says the world's lost a
towering global leader russian president
vladimir putin has expressed his deepest
condolences
gorbachev with this famous crimson
birthmark was one of the most
recognizable figures of 20th century
politics and one of its most influential